will be young ladies on faults
what do you mean
there's only one young lady on that poll
mccollum goes down the middle and dunks
[Applause]
great find by gasal
spun under pressure mccollum picks his
pocket on the push looking to tie the
ball again
[Applause]
and we're even at 82. i'm late to crab
oh he had a layup
and then mccullough he downtown
[Applause]
passed up the three twice
cj always spun dirt completely around
and hit the three
that's worse than a poster a spin around
you know it just depends on
how much offensively the other team
had it mccollum find his way through
that crowd and then banked it in
porzingis so you can double team him
without him knowing it oh mccollum with
the right hand went baseline had a
couple of white shirts hanging on him
and still spun it off the glass his
hands and cj's razors down two nine
seconds mccallum takes it off the
dribble for the tie yes
5.4 left timeout washington jay has
timeouts if he wants him
midcourt dribbles gets to the lane gets
bump scores and he's fouled
7.6 left
and a chance at a three-point play to
clear out as he went down
cj baseline
score the bucket and he's fouled he
never dribbled again off the glass
and leroy richardson says count it
better defense this time and that's been
the surprising thing i think is cj oh
what a move gets himself to the middle
scores and he's fouled
boy what a crossover to freeze the
defense
out of comes to mcconnell
freezes hollis jefferson on the davis
screen pumps of three hands
and comes down right to the cylinder
chris dunn being extra physical on cj cj
might be able
to draw a foul oh my goodness dunn
leaves cj he's wide open and nails a
three from way downtown and a career
high for cj mccollum outs trailing by
three plumlee to bring it in bounce from
the inline
they cast it outside cj and catch a shot
is that bad
catch and shoot three opening tie ball
game at
106.2 cj who's getting a screen for
plumbing
crosses over between defenders and laid
it up and in what a magnificent move
that was as the blazers now pulled it
within 14 and a timeout call by the
warriors he said i'm living the dream
he's got six threes here's mccullum two
seconds left mccullum gets rid of
matthews lets it fly at the horn
[Applause]
with the long two to end the first half
celtic games in the 80s
mccullum into the lane beautiful play
going to the right hand around powell
and a timeout by dallas
lovely looking cj open works between
matthews and barnes into the
lane three tenths of a second remaining
for the dallas mavericks they got a
heaven harris will down the floor it
comes and he overshoots the rim blazers
win the middle of the paint
blazers led by as many as thirteen
you don't see that very often but when
you do
you got to replay that one at some point
cj with the hammer
here in this ball game
and the blazers down one here's cj into
the lane banged it up and he stumbles as
he fell over the fallen defender right
away look
shot contested
crab recovers cj on the flow behind the
back into the lane feathers it up and in
what a magnificent move
erkicks came here in a late season deal
with denver and they went 14-6 once they
got good feed
mccullum
beautiful play on his belly there in
front of the bench
cj comes off the screen of turner turns
the corner rams into brooks recovers and
scores
at the end of the second quarter cj
mccollum will have the last word
lakers trailing here by three
cj the other way look at that crosstalk
oh
come on
[Music]
to cj 13 seconds as he brings it across
mid court on the nurkic screen cj into
the lane running right hander up hangs
on the iron and rolls in blazers take
the lead 111 to 110 san antonio ball
they use timeout with five and nine ten
seconds remaining in the game that's
stevenson to defend as well he's a good
defender
maybe your inbounds to cj fires over
corey joseph three's up and in
how about that
cj says never give in or does he is he
just playing the uniform at this point
to play a legend here oh
my goodness pick him up somebody pick
him up clean up on al three
[Laughter]
[Applause]
welcome thought three two
two
charge on mccullum so he gets rid of it
they're in denial making sure somebody
else has got to take over
great play by mccullum along the
baseline
hung in the air and then banked it in
got down there
to challenge the shot and stayed off
that rim he was oh
hey
tying up
[Applause]
dribble handoff to cj
goes right up the gut to the right
bringing it down the pike with a
two-hand jam that's how you start
overtime
dante exum who's done a nice job off the
bench play-making and playing defenses
in
deep three by cj mccollum
[Music]
late in the clock it's cj mccollum
throwing it out to aminu for three
needed that one it felt like still
operating blazers
trying their best to put them away cj
into the lane contact
floats it up and in send the man to the
line
slowly goes right at your slayer blocked
by jokic and the rebound throws it ahead
murray murray down the court jeff block
oh mccullum with a block he said
basically i don't i don't want to be
considered somebody you can attack is
that i'm the weak spot on our team
beautiful pass by mccullum
leaving it for a cutting white side
cj dame high catch swatted away by ubra
cj recovers gets off the three beats the
clock nothing but net for the first time
at gary trent junior
cj sets his feet drives bembry to the
end and eases it over the cup before
parker could get there yeah he he snuck
him on that one to protect the paint on
pick and roll
so they're not up to contest the three
the same as zubach does it this
feed mccullum slick pass for nurkic
and a foul call
damn catches it in the back court 13
seconds left to go for the blazers they
trail by one
dame into the paint fights cj cj for
three oh painted cj mccollum
blazers take the two-point lead
cj with his ninth three of the knights
they work so well together they don't
care who gets the shine
cj's
blazers just trying to match them shot
for shot that string together some stops
cj down the paint draws the foul and the
bucket
cold shots wants them to just play
blazers have a chance here cj
ball in hand rises up for two it's good
[Applause]
tipped in though by gobert with 1.1 left
nurkic fires it down court caught by
mccullum got away and scores at the
buzzer
what a pass down the court by nurkic
[Music]
column
in his bag oh like the fries are at the
bottom
[Music]
lillard eight assists 21 points van
bleep
inside the bar rejected by cj
spikes it away powell lead past a little
into the lane outside the dame a dribble
adjustment for three got it